[Music
] Héctor Mejía greets you with the headlines
for today, Friday, December 4, one of
the busiest airlines at the
airport marketing warned that they are
facing almost 7,000 temporary layoffs due
to the impact of the pandemic sea
kuester lines announced that for the first
time in history  of the company are
facing cuts to their workforce
the airline has been trying to
work with unions to avoid
layoffs the 50+ year old company
said they have seen
billion dollar losses
the nevada national guard will continue to
support efforts  against the
coronavirus the governor says
that the bank announced that the extension for now will be
maintained until March of next year
since April elements of the guard have
helped in the administration of tests
for the coronavirus as well as the
contact tracing support in the
laboratories and the  food distribution
a judge is expected to decide hears the
president's campaign demand
trump te in which they demand that the
results of the elevated election be
considered invalid on Thursday lawyers for
the president presented what they say
that evidence that supposedly shows
that at least 40,000 Nevadans would have
voted twice and that they also
found names of deceased people such
as  Voters and also signatures that
were allegedly not verified
Clark County will begin
counting the votes Monday in at least one
race for the C District Commission
The Republican Set-Between and
lost the election to Democrat
Rush Best by just 10 votes in tennis
requested the count which is estimated to
be completed by next Friday
and now a look at the
weather forecast light winds for this Friday
sunny skies and a little warmer
temperatures in the 60s for
southern nevada and for the weekend
temperatures more  mild in the range of
the high 60s thanks for your company I
am héctor mejía and this  It was his brief
informative news now el espanyol
[Music]